o médico argentino e nada melhor que
começar com uma história
eu vim de uma família muito simples
simples no sentido de nunca passei fome
sempre tive o que vestir mas passei por
muita dificuldade financeira
meu pai ele sempre foi vendedor
ambulante ele uma em caxias do sul no
rio grande do sul já faz bastante frio
eu acho que é semelhante aqui e ele
vendia hostil uma pantufa um chinelo
para dentro de casa
minha mãe sempre foi empregada doméstica
ou trabalhava como cozinheiro por vários
períodos
ela ajuda o meu pai a aula fabricavam
chinelos é o chinelo e meu pai vendia e
com isso eles criaram eu e minha irmã e
meu irmão eu sou o caçula o número é
dois anos mais velho que eu e meu irmão
com 23 anos de idade ele já tinham então
mais três
meu pai eu me lembro disso é muito claro
na minha mente todo o mercado na padaria
no bar no mercado da esquina no mercado
de outra rua meu pai devia lá e eu
sempre tinha aqui no mercado e quando
não tinha mais nenhum mercado pra ele
pagava uma conta desses mercados de
voltar para lá
a gente grava conta ele ia criava em
outra e assim foi indo por bastante
tempo
ele sempre também pegava muito dinheiro
emprestado com a minha avó era cobradora
de ônibus já não ganhava muito dinheiro
se ele estava pegando dinheiro
emprestado com ela e com isso eles foram
criando nós três lembro de uma cena
muito forma na minha cabeça é muito
forte
um dia eu queria tomar um chocolate lado
e eu pedindo pra minha mãe e ela me deu
eu comprei ao chegar em casa ela falou
tomar no banheiro porque como é muito
pequenininho
vocês não podem é não dá para dividir
para muitas pessoas
e assim foi não encontro uma história
também que eu com quando era 94 tinha
cinco anos de idade o menino mais velho
sempre me convidaram pra jogar bola na
rua e eu ia e com isso 94 no corpo muito
bem que o brasil foi tetracampeão me
lembro dos bairros alto do galvão bueno
ela ficou muito marcado para mim e com
isso nasceu a paixão de jogar futebol na
sua paixão pelo futebol
então comecei a fútil muito futebol com
meu pai jogava na rua jogava na escola
com oito anos falei para meu pai que eu
queria ser jogador de futebol com nove
anos eu e ele me colocou nas categorias
de base do caxias que o time local lá na
cidade
e assim foi eu queria ser um jogador de
futebol e hoje a minha compreensão é
muito forte
não queria ser um jogador de futebol eu
queria dar uma vida melhor para minha
mãe
esse era o meu sonho queria dar uma vida
melhor para minha mãe
enfim depois disso o tempo foi passando
a membro com o lema de uma parte também
que meu pai falou que também isso torci
muito resultado pra minha vida ele falou
é deposto quer ser jogador de futebol o
jogador não bebe não fuma e hoje com 30
anos nunca fumei nunca houve nenhum tipo
de droga eu acho que o bb uma vez quando
tinha 15 anos de ressaca porque uma
menina tinha ficado fora como os 14 anos
então eu conheci o beijo na boca e não
em outras coisas e por coincidência com
16 com os 15 e 16 anos
eu desisti de jogar futebol beleza mas a
vida não para a gente precisa continuar
com a vida certo então junto quando eu
estava fazendo ensino médio junto fiz o
do senai
eu não queria e oficinas de construção
civil eu não queria fazer o senai a que
eu quero ter uma profissão eu tava de
olho só nos 250 reais que ganha com o
menor aprendiz
nessa época eu estava andando de skate
eu precisava comprar as peças era cara
mais 250 reais dava para o gasto
beleza então depois na vida ela foi
desenrolando foi fazendo 17 18 anos
o meu primeiro emprego eu acho que tem
16 anos foi fechando à ihu on line
porque não sabe o limite com capeletti
só com grid italiani página eu ganhava a
fortuna de 80 centavos a hora depois do
senai trabalhar de servente de pedreiro
ok
depois eu fui trabalhar numa empresa de
carga e descarga numa transportadora
nessa transportadora depois de uns
quatro meses abriu uma vaga para
atendente trabalhar com direto com o
cliente trabalhar no escritório eu só
estava de olho não queria mais trabalhar
no chão de fábrica iria trabalhar no
escritório hok fui lá eu fui lá falei
com a um encarregado e eu falei que
estava cursando administração um detalhe
só não falei pra ele que a administração
que estava fazendo era um cursinho de
r$20 que eu pagava e era uma vez por
semana
mas enfim eu consegui a vaga depois de
oito meses
eu fui demitido de seu emprego logo
depois eu comecei a trabalhar em outro
nesse outro emprego também comecei a
trabalhar no chão de fábrica era uma
empresa que era uma empresa que vende
ferramentas que importava da china bem
legal e abre uma vaga para trabalhar com
photoshop ganhava em média uns duzentos
reais a mais do que eu estava vendo na
época só que trabalhava no escritório eu
não gostava de trabalhar no chão de
fábrica se vocês já perceberam e com
isso beleza foi lá ela precisava era de
sobre designer gráfica vaga e eu
precisava aprender photoshop coreldraw e
eu não entendia nada disso não sabe
disso
a mesa precisa aprender lá comprei um
curso comprei umas aulas particulares em
uma escola que tinha em caxias na cidade
era 250 reais é um pouco menos da metade
do meu salário mas fiz fui lá fiz o
curso me candidatei a vaga ganhar a vaga
nessa empresa tinha um cara boa pinta
tinha um caminhoneiro é tão cara bonito
ele tinha uma namorada bonita foi cara
que esse cara faz descobrir que ele
arrumava os computadores né ele ia lá no
escritório um computador precisa
aprender isso né cara bonito cara boa
pinta tem carro legal pelo carro eu
achava que ele tinha muito dinheiro
namorada bonita foi um cara vou virar
técnico informática também e com isso
comecei a estudar prass e técnico em
informática
só que eu não ganhei o dinheiro que eu
imaginava que iria ganhar e não ganhei
então eu acho que eu trabalhei uns cinco
seis anos um técnico em informática e eu
um 23 anos era o tipo cara que não dava
certo e nada
23 anos já tinha passado por menos de
dois anos já tinha passado por mais oito
empregos
eu tinha tentado duas empresas de
marketing multinível na época tinha
tentado uma micro franquia enfim não
dava certo
nada é o sonho se tornasse o futebol ele
não existia mais
mas o sonho de dar uma vida melhor para
minha mãe sim respirar
um dia chego em casa à casa de madeira
pequena
chamei minha mãe mãe mãe eu sabia que
ela estava em casa
a bolsa dela estava no sofá
eu acho que todo mundo tem mãe aqui o
grande imã a a grande maioria
eu vi minha mãe chorando sem entender
que fui e ela estava chorando porque ela
não tinha 150 reais para apagar uma luz
e eu com 89 anos de idade não tinha
muito que fazer mas com 23 sim e eu não
tinha como ajudar aquele momento aquele
dia
mal consegui dormir foi muito difícil
dormir aquele dia olhei pra cima
falei cara minha vida será que é isso eu
imaginava que com 23 ano eu ia ser um
jogador de futebol
e pra mim com 89 anos e jogador de
futebol era ser rico e rica que nem eu
nem o barulho era na mentalidade de
criança beleza precisava fazer alguma
coisa a respeito de tudo isso né
essa parte meu irmão que é mais velho
seis anos mais velho do que eu
com 2 13 anos ele começou a se envolver
com droga com 15 ele começou a fumar
crack
há 15 anos e começava com o fato fumar
crack além de então tava muito presente
eu fui criado muito presente com
violência dentro de casa é muito forte
dificuldade financeira e com meus oito
nove anos eu não me recordo
eu vi uma pessoa tem overdose na minha
frente
imagina uma criança de oito nove anos
tendo overdose na frente
esse é o tempo
imagina uma criança vendo isso tudo bem
com 17 18 participam uma depressão daí
falaram que eu teria que eu teria que ir
a um psiquiatra tomar remédio ele não
deixou o curar sozinho ok me curei e
contudo essas histórias eu falei preciso
fazer alguma coisa a respeito preciso
fazer alguma coisa da minha vida
com 23 anos então eu estava um pouco eu
acho que eu tava com 22 e como eu estava
trabalhando de técnico em informática
numa empresa e dessas tentativas de
empreender
eu ouvia muito dizer que isso fizesse
uma pessoa de sucesso tem que mandar uma
pessoa de acessos à beleza e qualquer
forma de fazer isso para quem não tinha
condições
eu entendi me falaram que era livros bom
livro eu posso ler eu tenho dinheiro
tipo ou posso baixar enfim eu posso dar
um jeito na minha cabeça e um dia era
essa empresa é bem pequena estava eu e
meu chefe é chefe não estava naquele dia
era só eu ou outro técnico o meu chefe
ea esposa dele cuidava da parte
administração sexta feira não tinha
nenhum cliente para atender fiquei lá
baixar o pdf do livro pai rico pai pobre
foi o primeiro livro que eu li
eu me lembro que eu li 70 80% desse
livro
naquela tarde e depois de uns 30 40 dias
depois eu tinha pedido demissão dessa
empresa e daí eu fui tentar empreender
numa dessas empresas que eu falei pra
vocês de marketing de rede
um ano se passou não deu certo não é um
modelo de negócio que eu estava feliz
enfim cheguei em casa um dia de noite
comecei a pesquisar como ganhar dinheiro
online como
o terreno a isto como se fazer uma
pesquisa e descobriu marketing digital
eu falei poxa ilegal washington
informática enfim eu gosto de
computadores eu gosto de internet sou
apaixonado pela internet começou em uma
jornada o marketing digital
ok há um ano eu comecei então e pra
complementar minha renda comecei a
trabalhar de garçom comecei a trabalhar
como entregador entregava bolachas e
biscoito em gramado que é bem pertinho
de caxias ali comecei a vender perfume e
eu formava comprou computadores ainda
pra mim conseguir sobreviver
meus pais não tinham condições de me
ajudar morava com eles mas eu tinha
minhas contas pessoais
mas eu já estava com 23 anos e com
aquilo foi um ano se passou e eu
tentando é tentado a acontecer e com
marketing digital com tentando te renda
e o tempo foi passando um ano então as
pessoas ano houve muitos amigos
familiares
muitos familiares vizinhos tipo não quer
nada com nada fica o dia inteiro na
frente do computador
édipo é aquilo a única diferença do
gênio por um louco são os resultados
essa é a única diferença foi que estava
numa situação que eu falava pra mim
declarou acredito em mim o que eu vou
fazer da minha vida e eu persistir
comecei a iffhs trabalho de graça para
uma pessoa pra aprender
comecei no mais uma vez uma
webconferência estava eu porque não tava
numa breve conferência com esse cara que
da tailândia travam um cara das
filipinas eu estava um cara de são paulo
e outro de goiânia era um que não falava
inglês daquela vez e eu estava ali
porque como fazer o trabalho de graça
pra esse cara eu poder ele deixou ali e
como já estava um ano estudando
eu já sabia algumas coisas de teoria e
eu comecei a ajudar um amigo um cara que
tava na webconferência ele queria lançar
um produto dele pela internet era
personal trainer e depois de um tempo
uma das coisas que aprendi na minha vida
se a eu não fico esperando a
oportunidade de chegar ao sempre gerou
uma oportunidade de ouvir uma
oportunidade de ajudar e eu falei cara
tô trabalhando como consultor de
marketing digital não tá
trabalhando e eu comecei a cobrar 500
reais dele por mês
show 500 reais já me ajudava muito vocês
não têm noção e daí ele como eu comecei
a ajudar ele e ele me deu 10% do produto
dele a gente fez o primeiro lançamento
dele de 20 mil reais o ganho os dois mil
reais
depois eu trabalhei uma equipe de som e
de suporte de um lançamento que o legal
as pessoas geravam boleto para comprar o
curso online e hoje eu ligava de cada
ligação que o ligava e fechava à venda
ganhava 250 reais e eu fiz seis mil
reais numa semana
procurava 6 horas da manhã via até às
nove da noite ligando ligando depois
disso fechou uma outra consultoria
depois disso outra pois um cliente me
indicou para o outro
depois o isso no meu quarto no meu
quarto eu fiz isso hoje
depois isso foi em 2013 hoje e 2014 eu
realmente comecei a ganhar dinheiro eu
fiz meu primeiro milhão de reais pela
internet eu tenho dez funcionários já
vem de mais de 10 milhões de reais
através dos meus textos e hoje vou falar
o que é isso e a grande lição que fica
para mim disse que é sucesso
é uma decisão e eu volto a repetir
a única diferença de um louco para os
gênios são os resultados
ok contei toda essa história agora deixa
eu falar como eu montei essa história eu
só compro 80 copyright é basicamente a
pessoas que escreve textos persuasivas
pru prospecto tomar uma ação seja a
venda seja um click seja qualquer coisa
qualquer ação que eu quero que o
prospecto tony e eu me especializei
nisso eu sou especialista martins tal eu
me especializei então 14 hayden no
brasil não é muito
ana é muito comum externo seria tipo uma
redação publicitária mas é muito
diferente e eu eu eu comecei a fazer
isso então a ami a especializar em
marketing digital
quando a primeira vez um dos elementos
mais fortes
sem dúvida nenhuma de que da persuasão é
história
não existe existe outros elementos mas a
história dos mais fortes ea primeira
estrutura que eu conheci foi de joseph
campbell que a jornada do herói que são
dois passos e pra mim é muito difícil
quando escreveu os textos para clientes
parceiros do colocar nesses dois espaços
e algum tempo eu fui otimizando e eu
deixei isso em quatro passos que é o
herói na vida comum e desafios e
derrotas
a descoberta e resultados toda minha
história desses quatro passos herói a
vida comum falei da minha infância
falei pra vocês meus pais como eles
foram criados como eu e os meus irmãos
como eu fui criado da dificuldade
financeira desafios e derrotas
a cena da minha mãe todo o desafio
também de tudo meu irmão lhe deles é
usuário de drogas e tudo mais
a descoberta eu tenho duas descobertas
na minha história que o primeiro são os
livros e o segundo é o marketing digital
e os resultados o que essas descobertas
são os resultados que essa descoberta me
trouxe a outra ela fala que toda
história tem que ter três elementos o
evento gatilho como foi o vento gatilho
da minha história o primeiro foi a cena
da minha mãe e o segundo evento gatilho
foi o livro depois 30 40 dias eu tinha
pedido demissão ea moral da história né
qualquer moral da história dessas que
essa é uma decisão e tudo isso há a
história ela tem três grandes objetivos
conexão primeiro quando estou falando da
vida comum e quando eu quero vender um
produto ou serviço não quero falar com
todo mundo quer falar com o público alvo
específico e quando eu tô falando da
vida comum eu estou criando conexão é um
dos primeiros objetivos um dos três
objetivos é a conexão e criar interesse
quando eu tô falando da descoberta de
desafios estou criando conexão e os
desafios é muito importante criar pontos
em comuns de dor quando eu já contei
essa história em outros lugares eu
recebo direto todo dia no instagram as
pessoas falam cara parece contar minha
história porque eu tô falando com um
público alvo específico
e eu falo com eles e assim eu consigo
conectar depois da descoberta o que fez
o que ele descobriu o marketing digital
e os livros ou gera interesse de
terceiro a o terceiro grande objetivo
então primeira é criar conexão o segundo
é criar interesse que através da
descoberta e o último ensinar comprar
desde a desde que eu vou falando da vida
comum do herói até a parte dos
resultados eu tô em se dando no público
alvo a comprar uma parte que eu vou
falar aqui pra vocês eu me emocionei de
verdade mas também de propor de forma
proposital porque eu me emocionando eu
consigo criar um ponto em comum com o
meu público é o mesmo sonho sempre nessa
parte então não é um teatro sempre me
emociono
mas eu preciso te pontos em comuns com o
público pra mim consegui criar esse
rapoport então esses são os três grandes
objetivos do mastodon quando você vai
contar uma história quando você quer
vender seu produto serviço e através
dessa estrutura já vem de mais de 10
milhões de reais entre os produtos entre
os produtos os meus parceiros
entre os produtos e serviços dos meus
clientes com quem eu acho que é isso
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]